I'm now about to mention a name that
usually comes above the title because
he's won six Oscars is writer and
director of such movies as Lost Weekend
Sunset Boulevard and the apartment he's
had an astonishing total of 21
nominations for such others as ninotchka
hold back the dawn ball of fire Double
Indemnity
Foreign Affair the big carnival Stalag
17 Sabrina witness for the prosecution
and some like it hot ladies and
gentlemen here is the eminent
illustrious charming funny and
magnificent Billy Wilder
it says in the Bible in the fifth book
of the New Testament chapter 20 verse 35
it says there it is more blessed to give
than to receive
I don't believe that here then are the
nominations for this year's Director's
Award and the nominees are first and
Peterson in this boat Steven Spielberg
for et2 Exeter
richard attenborough for Gandhi
Sydney [ __ ] for two teams
and Sydney lament for the verdict
and here ladies and gentlemen is your
verdict the winner is Richard
Attenborough
ladies and gentlemen fellow members of
the Academy without Joe child and Jacob
Earth's and the National Film
Development Corporation of India the
film would not have been made without
Marty Baum I would never have been able
to maintain my courage I am totally
bowled over by this and I think an
enormous contribution to my holding it
must go to Frank price and Columbia
Pictures for their courage in agreeing
to distribute it there are many people I
would like to thank and some of you some
you have already honored but I would
simply say to Sidney Lumet and Sydney
[ __ ] and Wolfgang Petersen and Steven
Spielberg company Thank you very
oh we're in the hole
my big movies are thundering to the wire
we've never had a dead he so to announce
the winner here is the dazzling
delightful and delicious Carol Burnett
the nominees for the best picture there
were so many wonderful ones I know it
was tough to pick one so here they are
ET the extra-terrestrial a story about
the children we all are and the
grown-ups we sometimes seem to be a
universal pictures production Universal
even still very facile Kennedy produces
Gandhi the biography of a man who
brought pride dignity and peace to his
nation and who even today inspires
millions of people with undying humanity
an Indo British Films production
Columbia Richard Attenborough producer
missing the story of a futile search for
truth and freedom and a land where such
things no longer exist the Universal
Pictures Polygram Pictures presentations
of an Edward Lewis production Universal
Edward Lewis and Mildred Lewis producers
Chuck see a human comedy of gender and
role-playing set in the world of
contemporary daytime television a mirage
punch production Columbia Sydney [ __ ]
and dick Richards producers the verdict
a story of law and medicine and the
human beings caught between them a fox
anak brown production 20th Century Fox
Richard DS zanuck and David Brown
producers
it should be a five white tie
Gandhi Richard Attenborough
ladies and gentlemen this should not be
a moment for regret in any sense but I
have to say that I have the regret that
my late partner moti Qatari to whom this
film was dedicated is not here to share
this award with me and to his widow
Dorothy and Sharma and Raj nee I send my
love and my very grateful things for the
fact that their father gave me the idea
of making this film members of the
Academy you have honored you have seen
fit to honor a number of people who have
been connected with this film Jack and
Band and Billy and many others and with
particularly without Jack and Ben there
would have been no movie but I'm sure
that they would agree that the person
whom you really honor has been been
suggested was Mahatma Ghandi himself he
was an inspiration to millions and
millions of people and the extraordinary
thing always seems to me that he is
currently still an inspiration your
great folk hero Martin Luther King jr.
was inspired by Mahatma Gandhi lack
valishia
that noble Polish Patriot came out of
prison the other day and said that what
he had been attempting to do in the past
was not going to work the only way in
which we could have fine human dignity
and peace was through the philosophies
and teachings of Gandhi Gandhi simply
asked that we should examine the
criteria by which we are judged the
manner
of solving our problems that surely in
the 20th century we human beings
searching for our human dignity could
find other ways of ultimately solving
our problems than blowing the other
man's head off he begged us to
re-examine that criteria he believed
that if we would but agree simplistic
though it being that we would not resort
to violence in the ultimate then the
rooms that we would take solving our
problems would be a quite different one
to the one that we accept now in the
acceptance of ultimate confrontation he
begged us to re-examine that criteria I
believe he had something to say to all
of us everywhere in the world and dear
colleagues in all truth because the
films that were nominated with me all
wished for the same thing all their
makers wanted to say the same thing and
in all truth it is not me or even Ben or
Jack or Billy that you truly honor
you honor Mahatma Gandhi and his plea to
all of us to live in peace
you